ils cherchaient tous leur qualificatif
aujourd'hui lors de la présentation de
la collection automne-hiver d'yves saint
laurent au choix sublime extraordinaire
merveilleux voilà pour les mots
donnèrent d'applaudissements pour le
bruit et coup d'oeil avec marie-josée le
picard et bernard connor à roeser
l'affluence des grands jours arrivaient
pour la collection d'yves saint laurent
personne ne vient s'asseoir tout est en
place
le premier modèle entre une robe grise
enfin les nages effet tonneaux à
l'ourlet
une grande tente de cosaques souvenir de
l'exposition de costumes russe organisés
l'hiver passé par saint laurent à paris
sans doute autant la collection va être
très parisienne avec une sobriété voulu
dans les formes et des jupes décidément
courte
les alliances tons vifs inattendu étonne
et ravit ce osé et réussi en couleurs
complémentaires pour le soir là mais
brillant et décolleté en orchidées nous
en cette saison totalement remplacer les
broderies
naturellement jusqu'aux films de vigueur
plus des fusils que jamais
il naturellement notre campus
poésie jeanmaire des gens voient les
sous un vent sweat shirt de velours noir
la mariée chez yves saint laurent n'est
jamais classique
celle ci crée la surprise avec sa robe
aux couleurs fausses et sa couronne de
blé